while walking around my neighborhood in
Austin I saw this advertisement on the
back of a U-Haul now I don't know about
you but when I think of U-Haul I don't
think of aerodynamics so I'm gonna put
their claims to the test I'm gonna make
U-Haul go Hypersonic but not this U-Haul
I'm going to make this U-Haul go
hypersonic
yeah depending on how things are going
we've got a mechanism we might even be
able to just cut this loose in an empty
Test Section and really see how
dynamically stable this guy is at Mach
7.
thank you
this is the stupidest video I've ever
made
foreign
to the University of Texas San Antonio
about two hours south of here they have
an extremely rare piece of equipment a
Hypersonic wind tunnel managed by none
other than Dr Chris Combs who you may
know as the laser-eyed Hypersonic
Professor on Twitter Dr Combs is
currently using it to test control
mechanisms for Hypersonic Vehicles
traveling in the upper atmosphere I let
the man himself explain the difficulties
in controlling a Hypersonic vehicle in
the upper atmosphere when you go up high
altitude all right you get high enough
up in the altitude where control
surfaces like flap flaps and fins don't
work anymore there's not enough drag
there's not enough aeroforce for that to
happen but you still need to be able to
move around and so usually we use
control jets and so like the space
shuttle a lot of space Vehicles you see
those using the little RCS that fire and
when you're out in space like properly
in orbit you're not worried about
interaction of aerodynamics it's
happening with that but there's some
Middle Ground where you're high enough
up in altitude where the flaps still
aren't effective but you're low enough
where you have air forces happening and
then suddenly you have this Hypersonic
airflow hitting your jet
and it rips the jet apart and you lose
Effectiveness and NASA has even seen
that for certain tests
you you know you imagine from a Newton's
Laws perspective you fire a jet one way
you move the other way kind of thing
that interaction gets so complex and
sometimes you fire the Jet and move the
same direction
that's a major problem for the new wave
of hypersonic aircraft being developed
you may be surprised to learn that icbms
travel much faster than any Hypersonic
Vehicles being developed
intercontinental ballistic missiles are
designed to exit Earth's atmosphere
travel extremely quickly at speeds of up
to 7.8 kilometers per second through
space and then suddenly dive on their
targets they move quickly but their
lofted trajectory gives their enemies
more time to detect and aim anti-missile
defenses Hypersonic missiles are
designed to cruise within the Earth's
atmosphere at about half the speed of an
ICBM the atmosphere slows them down but
their low trajectory means they suddenly
appear on the horizon previously been
hidden by the Earth's curve giving their
targets minimal time to detect and
intercept them so this Hypersonic wind
tunnel is an extremely useful tool for
companies and government agencies
looking to develop Hypersonic vehicle
an extremely useful tool that we are
going to use to test the vehicle
designed to move your old furniture
across the country at Mach 7. so it will
go
we'll face this way because airflow is
this direction I'm assuming you don't
let this go on box 7 in Reverse right
um so it'll get mounted basically like
that somewhere in the middle right yeah
hey maybe you know maybe that's a that's
a stretch goal depending on how much
time we have we don't have multiple of
them yeah so it's gonna sit right here
like that should we go ahead and unbox
this guy is it yeah someone's gonna get
him yeah we're gonna upset a collector
somewhere I'm sorry whoever's out there
watching this that's a U-Haul model
collector it has the original price on
it of seven dollars I got it for 40.
yeah I mean with inflation who knows how
much that's worth okay so yeah we're
it's gonna sit we're gonna take the flat
plate out it's going to be mounted like
that on the sting Eli you got a demo for
us for what kind of Sting Mount we're
probably talking about
is our variable angle of attack strut
that still has a cow on it or a couple
weeks ago yeah but yeah we'll need some
out because this has a quarter 20 thread
in the back so we need to yeah sorry
about how to mount the U-Haul yeah so
we'll uh gingerly remove that cow I
think
poor thing yeah exactly
that's nothing that the Vets don't do
too yeah I mean that's when I decided
not to be a vet I left a mark I was
calling they're like this is what your
job is now yeah
the results for the cow are excellent
groundbreaking bovine technology so how
does this wind tunnel get air to travel
at Mach 7 on one end is a big old vacuum
chamber and on the other is a
pressurized tube the two sides are
separated by a metal diaphragm that is
designed to pop at a Target pressure
differential you would think that
increasing the pressure would increase
the speed of air traveling between the
sections but it doesn't
one other little Nuance is people think
that you can if you increase the
pressure that should increase the Mach
number right that kind of conceptually
makes sense our Mach number is actually
fixed by the geometry it's just all
about expansion ratio so changing
pressure just changes the Reynolds
number and the the mass flux and the
equivalent altitude that you have but
the Mach number is 7.2 basically
regardless of what diaphragm that we use
and that's fixed by this shape that
shape is the shape of the nozzle which
works exactly like a rocket nozzle
rocket nozzles work by speeding up
exhaust gases from subsonic speeds to
supersonic speeds in the converging
section hitting Mach 1 at the throws at
which point the physics do a 180 turn in
rules and so what happens is
just like traffic on the Interstate if
you put I-35 down to one lane everything
stops all right everything's going slow
you add Lanes three four five six
everybody's able to speed up and spread
out
air molecules do the same thing once
they're going faster than Rock one my
friend not not just bikes might have a
some arguments yeah
um and so uh you're and you're really
you could expand this out more and go
higher Mach number but then you get
limited on the expansion end because the
pressure is getting lower the
temperature is getting lower and we're
actually already pushing the limits of
like verification with this so the
reason that we have insulation there on
that piece of pipe behind you is because
we actually heat up the air so these are
Big Cables To That Power electric
heaters that are wrapped around this
pipe and then we have insulation on it
so you don't burn yourself and it also
keeps the heat in all right we can heat
this pipe up to 700k 800 F what's the
purpose of eating it but so that the air
doesn't freeze in the free stream
um because even when we heat even when
we heat the free stream air basically
equivalent temperature like if it was
that if you were in the up expansion yes
the expansion so the energy has to come
from somewhere you can't cheat right and
so that energy is all going into the
momentum and the velocity of the gas
um but you lose the pressure you lose
the temperature so it all gets sapped
out what effect could that have on the
test with well literally freeze I assume
yes so what happens is
um really you scale it out with like
Reynolds number basically and so it's on
the one end the pressure being low is
more of an altitude consideration but
then you basically have temperatures
that aren't realistic right all right
and this is a problem in a lot of
hypersonic facilities and that we have
too because this is still a cold tunnel
we heat up to 700k and that's still cold
because the free stream equivalent air
temperature that we get is 60k right so
minus hundreds of degrees
it's cryogenically cold
really and that's just above the
liquefaction Point all right so you're
really just heating so that you're
actually keeping it above the
liquefaction yeah exactly that's what
you're trying to do liquid yeah so it
won't turn to it won't basically you
know you won't get condensation you
won't start to have things turn into
liquid and that's really all we're going
for because to get a True Flight
enthalpy we'd have to heat up to 2000k
or so which you hit material limits for
stainless in your driver tube pipe
things like that so there are very few
facilities that actually operate that
way you have to go into a completely
different mechanism to run those types
of tunnels so in summary this machine
essentially builds a pressure
differential between the vacuum on one
side and a long pressurized tank on the
other to drive air through a converging
diverging nozzle this pressurized site
is designed to be as long as possible
because a longer tube equates to a
longer test the test may occur in the
blink of an eye but with a high speed
camera we can capture a lot of data when
a long column of air is traveling by
instead of a short one so onto the test
itself but it wasn't all smooth sailing
when we started to pressurize the system
some pressure gauge readings started to
glitch out and this was a big problem
because those pressure gauges were
needed to trip the camera trigger box
without the triggering box we have to
manually get the camera to record when
it's supposed to right and we have
basically
a one second window of camera buffer
so Eli is either gonna fix the trigger
box while in the like 40 minutes that
the vacuum is getting pulled down or if
you can't fix that short then we're
gonna sit here and then when you hear
when we hear the diaphragm burst smack
the trigger button and that should catch
it
Okay so
that's what that's the status right now
and so began a mad scramble by Eli to
find the source of the problem we knew
the problem was being caused by a short
circuit so it was a matter of unplugging
everything until we could track down the
faulty Parts with only 40 minutes before
the test was due to start I was clearly
anxious but with all hands on deck and
Eli's understanding of the machine we
did manage to find the culprit and
proceeded to smash it
for the last hour and a half
freaking microcontrollable so it's just
their drainer board was broken yeah it
was
it was running the code but it was not
outputting the voltage okay so you just
replace yeah just pop in a new board
we're exciting
with that we could finally get the
tunnel up to pressure but first we had
to lock the place down for safety
now last thing I'm gonna do is to let
the surrounding Labs know that we're
gonna pressurize so we have a laser Bell
that will ring uh to let the other labs
know a laser Bell it may not be obvious
there but when I heard laser Bell I
assumed it was some sort of over
complicated sci-fi laser actuated Bell
and was clearly confused a laser Bell
only to slowly realize that it was in
fact just a normal Bell to tell people a
laser was in use oh it's pretty short to
tell people that there's there's a laser
in okay this laser is blind the out
of you
enough
I'm not sure doing this on camera stuff
was the right call at this point we just
had to wait for the pressure
differential to get high enough to burst
the diaphragm
now we just hope it doesn't get to 300
and like not burst and then we're like
what's going on these these diaphragms
with this score depth can burst
safely to like 320 PSI yeah I don't know
if I trust the model to survive a 320
PSI yeah
so uh okay that was not the sound I was
expecting
I was expecting a bit more of a boom
yeah like a prolonged part yeah it's
like a big metallic part yeah so I
turned off the buffer tank so we're not
still pushing it through there uh if you
want to turn off the right to file just
so we don't save excess
yeah yeah yeah absolutely all right I
want to lose the data stop the right to
file then I'm gonna turn off the vacuum
pump and then before we all go out there
I'm gonna poke my head out do a safety
go ahead check
so the group of overexcited nerds headed
outside to review the high speed footage
okay there goes the release
so it's flying now
oh yeah this is great we've got the bow
shock set up this is perfect
yes did we get it stable we got it
the U-Haul stable
oh my God
oh it's starting to tip down now oh
that's incredible
yeah it's starting as the more it tips
down the more it's catching the hood
yeah right
unfortunately the viewing window for the
test is pretty small but in the words of
Dr Combs I don't know what we learned
but I'm excited the two bow shock waves
result in some funky Shockwave
interactions on our static tests where
we fixed the truck in place the cab
vibrated widely which honestly the fact
this little plastic model held up to a
Hypersonic blast of air is impressive so
with all this data we do get an idea of
how a Hypersonic U-Haul May behave so I
had her wonderful animator Eli create an
artistic depiction of what a full-scale
Hypersonic U-Haul test may look like
sides it's a wonderful thing so what did
we learn that Dr Chris Combs is a fun
guy that Hypersonic wind tunnels are
pretty neat that I need to learn to
speak more clearly on camera and that
U-Hauls are absolutely not designed for
Hypersonic flight but the thing I'm most
curious about what became of the U-Haul
model we may need to wait a year or two
to find that out and then like I said
hopefully you know maybe we try a free
flight test
actually happen so you just let it go
and it just flies back yeah is there
like a mesh back here or something
that'll catch it no it's gonna go
there's a graveyard of models down in
the bottom of that right now and
periodically we get an undergrad to go
fish stuff out it was funny when I so
this vacuum tank was custom there's this
company in Ohio that makes vacuum tanks
like this and
when uh I called them to one of the
conversations we had where we were you
know kind of specking this thing out
and I said hey could we put some extra
access flanges on the side there oh yeah
sure no problem how big and then I'm
kind of just thinking out loud on the
phone I was like about how big do you
think it would need to be for a student
to fit their arm inside and they're like
what are you making man
yeah I was like who's our smallest
gratitude yeah right into this thing
yeah I mean I do I do joke that it's big
enough to fit grad students in there
that have misbehaved
um you know as sort of a threat so if
we've learned anything you don't want to
misbehave in Dr Combs program but you
can still learn from him in the safety
of your own home I've uploaded our uncut
tour of the Hypersonic wind tunnel to
nebula it's over 27 minutes long and
full of fun moments that I would have
loved to have included in this video
I think I should open the video if this
is not sponsored by U-Haul yeah
Bush got cut down to package a video
more suitable to the YouTube algorithm
relatively higher paced and not dwelling
too long on any singular point you can
get access to that now with a huge
discounted price of just 250 a month
using the link in the description this
money goes directly to our team we do
our best to give back by uploading early
and ad-free this video has already been
on nebula for over two weeks and the
next episode of real engineering is now
on nebula 2. detailing the incredible
engineering behind Japan's new magnetic
levitation trains we also upload
exclusive bonus videos like this on Cut
interview and upload original
documentaries like our Logistics of
D-Day series and the Battle of Britain
series but it's not just my exclusive
videos it's your other favorite
YouTubers too like mustard practical
engineering Neo and Wendover Productions
all all for the price of just 250 a
month I've done my best to push the
envelope of what YouTube can be with
in-depth engineering videos but there
are some small things I need to
sacrifice in order to succeed here I
used to explain equations completely in
older videos variable by variable but I
could see in our analytics that I would
lose 50 of the audience during those
moments now I just show you the
equations and allow viewers to pause if
they have interest now we have spikes of
attention in those moments on nebula I
don't need to worry about things like
this it's where our biggest fans watch
our videos the ones that aren't bored by
slower more in-depth videos that's why I
upload uncut interviews like this there
because people actually want to watch
them on nebula so if that sounds like
you please sign up and support our
channel for a massively discounted rate
of just 250 a month